[موسيقى]
في منطقة ياناكا في طوكيو ،
هناك شعور بالحنين إلى الماضي ، فهي واحدة
من أقدم المناطق في المدينة حيث تصطف المعابد
القديمة والمتاجر والمنازل في
أزقة متعرجة تذكرنا بماضي طوكيو الذي
لم تمسه كارثة طبيعية وحرب
تمكنت ياناكا من الحفاظ على
تقاليدها  الشكل والمظهر بالإضافة إلى
طريقة الحياة ، هذا هو جمال طوكيو
، أعتقد أنه يمكنك الحصول على أكثر من
مبانٍ جميلة في نفس الوقت ، لديك
أماكن تقليدية حقًا مثل
هذه
هنا في مفهوم فندق هانا الجديد
الذي يعمل على  دمج الزائرين مع
المجتمع المحلي ، فأنت لا تمنحهم
الرجال في المنطقة الشمالية ، وبالتالي أطلقنا عليها Shaco ،
لذلك قمنا ببناء فكرة وضع
استقبال الفندق في مكان واحد ،
والغرف في مكان آخر ، والأنشطة
الأخرى أيضًا في مواقع مختلفة حتى تتمكن من
استخدام  المدينة بأكملها كفندق واحد أعتقد
أن هذه كانت المرة الأولى التي أركب فيها
الدراجة في طوكيو ، لكنها كانت رائعة حقًا
أعتقد أنك تعرف اليوم أنني أستخدم الكثير من
السيارات ولكني بحاجة إلى استخدام الدراجة
أنا وليه يجب أن أتجول لاكتشاف
جمال صغير حقًا لليابان فندق
بمفهوم جديد يجلب الحياة
لمجتمع طوكيو التقليدي في ياناكا
سواء كان يزور أحد
أقدم الأضرحة في اليابان أو استوديو صور عتيق
يتعلق بالعيش مثل  نمط الحياة المحلي
هنا في ياناكا يبدو وكأنه يسير بشكل
أبطأ ، يمكنني أن أجد أسلوب حياة لطيفًا ودافئًا
يمكنني أن أشعر أيضًا بالقمامة غير المدركة
للموسيقى الصينية